first thing every gentleman needs is a
good suit by which i mean a bespoke suit
never off the peg and kingsman suits are
always bulletproof so let's get you
measured and then whether you get the
job or not you'll have a lasting and
useful memento of your time at kingsman
that is a scene from 2014's kingsman the
secret service a film that has led to
both a sequel and a prequel it also made
a central location in that movie a
tourist attraction huntsman is located
on london's famed
savile row the row still makes the best
suits in the world but as we saw past is
meeting the present and future as
bespoke clothing adjusts with the times
finds different customers and cuts a new
path forward our jeff glor went there to
take a look
it's amazing how much it's changed here
oh yeah yeah
welcome to huntsman jeff great to be
here yeah inside 11 savile row the
patterns of famous clients past and
presence are unmistakable
lawrence olivier
eric clapton
david bowie
these were based off of gregory pecks
that's probably our most iconic tweed i
could never be that bold wearing that
but a house draped in nearly 175 years
of tradition
knows change is still necessary taj full
took over at huntsman in 2019. how does
someone become managing director at
huntsman
being able to
keep up with the times huntsman sits on
a narrow street in london that was first
occupied mostly by military officers
in the late 1840s the first tailor shops
opened here specializing in bespoke
clothing cut and made by hand for kings
and queens
world leaders and barons of business
through wars and pandemics savile row
has endured
but the last couple years have been
among the most consequential
let's take a closer look at the shoulder
during the pandemic huntsman pioneered
the teleporting bespoke experience
using 4k cameras and robots
not unlike at hospitals you can do
surgery remotely so let's speak to the
companies who do this so we spoke to a
couple of surgeons we spoke to a couple
of companies and then we came up with
our robot that works for us now within
seven cities in asia
on a full-time basis i can actually show
you here i've got the bunch in front of
me um what about this lovely tan barley
corn do you think the robot fitting is
just as good as
what
yeah with that because there's no actual
element where the robot is using an ai
or an algorithm it is the cutter looking
taking pictures and watching the fitting
process cutters create the template or
pattern on which all future garments for
a customer will be based so four panels
on a trouser two the two the same in the
front two at the back
jacket two front two side two back uh
two top sleeve two understood max
whitaker gave us a brief demonstration
how's that very good very good for the
first time yeah very good yeah i've seen
a lot worse okay
good
there are usually three fittings
involved in a bespoke suit a process
that typically takes two and a half
months to complete and starts around
eight thousand dollars per suit
everything is done on site
including the code making led by steve
venn who's going into his 30th year
including his apprenticeship how long
was the apprenticeship i'm still going
on
still going on my apprenticeship
there's not a day that goes by that i
don't
learn something new
think about something in a different way
everyone here has their job
yes everyone has their own skill sets
yeah so you either go i mean in this
room we're all coat makers um in the
other side of the room you've got
trouser makers so it's a very individual
and then you have waistcoat makers as
well and then obviously you've got the
cutters upstairs who
make the patterns what part of the
process are we in now
we've got to the stage
of the sleeves to go in so we've
measured the armhole and now we've got
decided shapeless sleeve to match up
with the armhole
steve i'd like to remind you before this
started you told me you were
uncomfortable on camera yeah
and you
now beautifully explain the process
uninterrupted
so congratulations thank you very much i
mean i've been doing it a good few years
yeah i should be able to talk about it
you can make anything work if you feel
the right way in it exactly susan bender
is a contributing editor at british
vogue who now also works with huntsman i
think when i first came here i was quite
terrified um it being like huntsman the
bastion of savile bespoke tailoring
but once you actually come in here it's
very relaxed and
it's nothing to be terrified of i have
to tell you i didn't expect to see
someone in denim
at huntsman
i think that's the freedom that um
bespoke talent can give to you they can
make you a denim suit if you want
that would be a real canadian tuxedo
definitely
bender has introduced a new look for the
modern hunts woman the idea is like it's
like replaceable parts yes so you can
design whatever you want so that
the jacket is constantly being used but
in different ways so you can add lapel
onto a jacket
all right so it's not a suitcase it's a
lapel it's a lapel it's great for you
perfect for travel one jacket five six
seven looks if not more
how long should
a really well made bespoke
garment lasts for
60 to 100 years if not longer
the tailors on savile row believe
bespoke is a lifetime commitment
and beyond
at huntsman the patterns of customers
who've passed away hang from the ceiling
as the business welcomes in new
customers many of whom had their
curiosity peaked by the kingsman movie
come on in
the most visited room
in the building in the film this fitting
room is transformed into a secret
entrance to a clandestine world of
espionage and intrigue since 1849
kingsman taylor's clothed the world's
most powerful individuals today's
visitor could be tomorrow's customer
so if we have a 12 year old customer who
walks through the door who's a kingsman
fan they're treated the same way as if
they're buying a bespoke garment from
start to finish
because times may change
but excellence will always be in fashion
this is something that you think fathers
can hand down to sons and then to
grandsons and mothers to daughters and
beyond without a question of that it's
something i'm looking forward to do with
my son and for me that is incredible
like there's so many things that you can
hand down watches and whatnot but being
able to wear something knowing that your
father or mother had worn it previously
is also just as fulfilling
size might be an issue that's all but
but
but how amazing even the women's suits
like being able to switch that lapel
it's such a tiny thing that makes such a
big difference i was i was on savville
road not too long ago just about a month
or so ago and i appreciated that it said
we are here for the finest men and women
why is it something so traditional there
yeah well you know they
kicked it up a notch and they came to i
wish i could afford it